The Me Too movement was called radical when
essentially it was just like,
women being like,
can we just work,
like, in peace without your dicks in our faces?
And the abortion rights movement has always been called radical.
But do you wanna say the word when it's literally,
just let me have my body.
It's, I don't even want extra.
I don't want anything special.
The reaction to feminism is not commensurate with the size
are the magnitude of the demands that we're making.
Is always been
commiserate with the size
of male discomfort with women having these simple things.
Almost funny to see at what lengths, like,
someone will go to in order to curb these very small
that we're asking for.
Like, the amount of money that spent,
like, even just as Harvey Weinstein case like that,
there were like millions and on trying to overturn his rape prevention.
And like, 100 women have accused you, dude,
like, what are you even.
Why are you focused?
Like, go get a. Get a wife.